Hollywood mogul Harvey Weinstein is
reportedly in sex rehab this morning
overseas at least 25 women have publicly
described inappropriate conduct by the
disgraced studio boss in an
investigation published yesterday The
New Yorker claims three women accused
Weinstein of sexual assault and Gwyneth
Paltrow and Angelina Jolie told the New
York Times that Weinstein sexually
harassed them
Jericka Duncan spoke with The New Yorker
reporter who uncovered an audiotape of
Weinstein admitting forceful touching
Jericka good morning good morning The
Weinstein Company is promising a full
investigation multiple sources past and
present employees told The New Yorker
they witnessed touching and groping by
Harvey Weinstein and one of his alleged
victims told us when she was 23 she
suddenly found herself alone inside his
New York City apartment he came back out
100% fully naked
Catherine Kendall's meeting with Harvey
Weinstein two decades ago it's still
fresh in her mind just give me a massage
just let me kiss you well you know if
you won't give me a massage then will
you at least pick up your shirt and let
me see your breasts and I'm like no I'm
leaving Ronan Farrow conducted a ten
month long investigation for The New
Yorker there are 13 women in this story
three of them are alleging rape one of
those women amber about Alana Gutierrez
says in 2015 Weinstein groped her and
tried to put his hand up her skirt she
went to the NYPD who asked her to wear a
wire
the next day Gutierrez recorded the
conversation as Weinstein tried to get
her into his hotel room the audio was
obtained by the New Yorker
sorry just used today Weinstein was
questioned by the NYPD but the Manhattan
district attorney declined to prosecute
him the weinstein company says it is
shocked and dismayed by the allegations
of extreme sexual misconduct and sex
assault which came as an utter surprise
to the board Farrow told me it appears
there is a reason it took 20 years for
this story to unfold as a culture of
fear but also a broad array of legal
instruments settlements that were used a
machine designed to keep these claims
quiet to keep Harvey Weinstein safe to
keep him employed described in detail in
this story is a legal and public
relations team that had that very goal
yes Weinstein's wife Georgina Chapman
told People magazine yesterday their
10-year long marriage is over they have
two children former president and mrs.
Obama said in part yesterday they were
disgusted by recent reports about Harvey
Weinstein Hillary Clinton said she was
shocked and appalled Weinstein hosted
numerous Hollywood fundraisers over many
election cycles for President Obama and
then Democratic nominee Clinton one
fundraiser at Weinstein's home in 2013
brought in over two million dollars
Jericka thank you it's just disgusting
disturbing all of it to read it in full
detail but I hear the tape too is very
chilling when you hear it because his
voice is so recognizable on that tape
and I'm sure more questions to come out
of this absolutely